chris starts us off in columbia south
carolina
hi chris welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi dave hi rachel how are you
great how can we help uh well i have two
kids
uh age nine and seven and i'm interested
in starting a
custodial brokerage account for them
would that be something you recommend
well anytime an account is open in a
kid's name it is a custodial account
because until you're 18 you cannot
legally
enter into a contract in the united
states
and so a parent or someone does it on
behalf of a child and that is a
custodial account
so if you open up a savings account if
you open up a mutual fund if you open up
529 if you open up uh anything in the
kids name
it is a custodial account that's the
nature of it okay
now having said that why do you want a
brokerage account for a kid
well we have savings accounts for them
but every other day they want me to go
to the bank and draw
money so they can spend it i figure in a
broker's account they can't get access
to it
well they can't get access to it anyway
unless you let them
yeah i guess uh i guess that was fun but
they're all
because they go to the bank for money
and they always want to go and
buy something and they just bugged me
about it's not funny but you know they
just asked about it
and i figured if i put in a brokerage
account investment at least
rather than growing interest rates i
guess yeah but i mean you're
for the convenience aspect is what's
bothering you because you're having to
go to the bank to get the money out
where they're they're 11 and 9.
is that what you said they're uh nine
and seven nine and seven so even younger
so yeah i mean at this this is like
basic level teaching kids about money i
mean all they really need to be doing is
giving a little saving a little spending
a little i mean it's not going to be
anything insane and so i mean not even
having you could
put some of their savings in the bank
and it's more long-term for them like
hey in the next month or two
if we want to save up and get something
but i would just keep cash at the house
at that young of age
uh depending on how much it is i mean if
they're getting like big chunks of like
birthday money or christmas money yeah
you can put it in the account
the savings account but anything else i
would have at home because especially
for your
you know your especially your
seven-year-old but your nine-year-old as
well like when they have
cash at home
yeah yeah so let's do this let me let us
give you the
uh junior's uh adventure pack which is
the financial piece junior for teaching
kids how that little kids how to handle
money
rachel and i wrote and we'll also give
you a copy of smart money smart kids
which is what rachel and i wrote about
parents teaching their kids about money
because that's really what this question
comes down to
okay now what we teach is the kids need
to learn
four things and rachel touched on this
they need to learn to work which is
where money comes from
they need to learn to give to spend
wisely
under the parents direction and uh
and of course to save and so the
difference is instead of opening a
brokerage
account to keep them from bugging you i
will put them on a system
that says kids my job is to help you as
your dad
learn how to handle money so when you're
old you're not one of those old broke
people
okay like all our freaking friends right
so uh
you know and so then they get
when our kids would earn some money in
quotes
for doing a chore like feeding the dog
or something really difficult like that
which you hardly break a sweat doing
right but they would earn money for
doing a chore then we would divide the
chore money we call it commissions
you're not on allowance you're on
commissions you're not
you you work you get paid you don't work
you don't get paid
then we would divide that up into those
three envelopes and the kit i'm going to
send you has three envelopes it has a
giving envelope a savings envelope and a
spinning envelope
and so if they get ready to say i want
to spend some money do you have it in
your spending envelope because we put
some in there from when you worked
and then you could have the discussion
of oh there's not enough money
well you're gonna have to wait and work
some more or you can have the discussion
of
you could buy you can buy that cheap one
if you want to buy it but it'll be
broken by friday
or you can wait a little bit and buy a
good one that will last you and you can
pass it down to your grandkids
and we had lots of value discussions
about purchases rachel generally just
bought it
daniel would be was was very purposeful
and goal-driven about his purchases
and uh denise was what compliant i don't
know didn't even spend money yeah
she didn't spend money she's a saver we
had to but you need to make
kids coach kids in all four areas
not working is not an option not being
generous is not an option
not saving is not an option not
spending money wisely is not an option
so you can't be only saving
or sometimes sweet little kids they want
to give all their money away well no
i don't want to teach you that way
that's it's i want to encourage you in
your generosity your outlandish
generosity
but you always should have some saved
and you should always have some
to spend as well yeah because i mean as
an adult
primarily those are the three things you
do with money i mean obviously your
saving can be
more complicated in investing and all
that but you basically that's what you
do with money you give save and spend
and so teaching those boundaries
is huge and then i mean and chris if
they're not doing like
just work around the house simple stuff
earning that money i mean
it's and again it's very age-appropriate
but man
it the award is amazing amelia or i
don't even tell you this
papa dave you'll be so proud okay i'm
ready she did
some chores and she what she did some
chores
what did she do she she actually swept
the kitchen i didn't even ask her to but
she was like mom can i sweet to earn a
dollar i was like sure
let's just do it because we have like 10
bucks and ones in our like little junk
drawer so that's what i like gave it to
her
so she did that carry plates to the sink
i mean she's she just turned five so
it's like
it's low ball stuff but well you don't
send the five-year-old to the salt mines
no so you do so we did we did
six and we went on amazon uh she bought
a poly pocket for 6.99 i paid the tax i
was like you know what i'm going to be
a graceful mother and just your five so
i was like i'll pay the taxes she saw
the six on amazon she's like it's six
mom at six and i have six dollars
and i was like yeah you're great yes
that's great but then she got very
confused
at the money was still there even though
the polly pocket arrived but i took her
money
and so the whole process of buying
online is very complicated for kids they
don't
quite understand it so it probably would
have been a little bit more beneficial
to like put on the masks and go to
target and buy but i was a little too
lazy so i was like we're just going to
amazon it all right
and have to walk through hey that's a
modern day that's still you did it
no yeah because what most parents do is
nothing well and the story wasn't about
me doing it but it but what i was going
to say is
the effects of what happened she she
made me like take a video of her to send
it to
a girl that babysits for us because she
was like tell maggie that i bought my
own polly pocket i was like okay so we
did it like
she was oh it was just it was amazing
she just
could not i mean talked about it for
three days so anyways it works
it gives anyone anyone who works and
earns
gains dignity as well as money that's
true not working does not give you
dignity
and so it's good that amelia's
sweeping the kitchen
she actually did pretty good hey i'm
back i bet she would yeah
all right so we've got a copy of smart
money smart kids and an adventure pack
to send from
junior to junior's teaching age
financial peace junior to teach the kids
how to do that stuff
to work to give to save and to spend
wisely this is the dave ramsey